♪ ♪
>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR OUR
DEFENDING THE FIRST SERIES,
WORRY EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, FREE
EXPRESSION, AND FREE THOUGHT
THOUGHT.
LAST NIGHT, WE TOLD YOU ABOUT
THE SHOCKING FACT ABOUT THE TECH
GIANTS WAR ON FREE SPEECH.
TONIGHT, WE LOOK AT HOW TO FIGHT
BACK AND THE FIRST THING TO DO
IS TO RECOGNIZE WHAT YOU ARE UP
AGAINST.
ONE THING THE LEFT DOES IS GIN
UP A PROPAGANDA WAR ON SO-CALLED
FAKE NEWS.
LET'S BRING IN REPORTER SHARYL
ATKISSON, HOST OF THE GREAT
SUNDAY SHOW "FULL MEASURE" ON
THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "THE
SMEAR: HOW SHADY POLITICAL
OPERATIVES CONTROL WHAT YOU SEE,
WHAT YOU THINK, AND HOW YOU
VOTE."
SO HAPPY SHE IS WITH US.
YOU ARE THE ONLY PERSON AT CBS
HE WAS EVER NICE TO ME.
I SAY THIS ALL THE TIME.
WE WORKED AT CBS TOGETHER.
WE ARE DELIGHTED YOU WERE WITH
US.
THIS DEFENDING THE FIRST SERIES,
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE, THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST BEST.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE UNDER
ASSAULT, ALL THESE FACT-CHECKERS
SEEM TO ONLY CHECK FACTS AND THE
NEGATIVELY ABOUT REPUBLICANS,
POLITIFACT, THEY SAY THE G.O.P.
LIES 32%, DEMOCRATS ONLY LIKE 8%
OF THE TIME.
ARE YOU FINDING THAT THE
FACT-CHECKERS NEED A
FACT-CHECKER?
>> I DEVOTED A CHAPTER TO
LOOKING AT THIS WHOLE IDEA TO
SHAPE AND CONTROL OUR NARRATIVE
IN MANY CREATIVE WAYS, TO CREATE
WHAT I CALL AN ARTIFICIAL
REALITY ONLINE AND ON THE NEWS
SO THAT PEOPLE THINK THAT THINGS
ARE TRUE THAT MAY NOT BE TRUE,
THAT THEY ARE AN OUTLIER IF THEY
HAVE CERTAIN FEELINGS WHEN THEY
MAY NOT BE.
THIS MAY BE MEDIA LITERACY
EFFORTS, MAY BE CALLED
FACT-CHECKING, MAYBE ANTI-FACT
NEWS --
>> Laura: WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
MAYBE LITERACY EFFORTS?
>> I NOTICE THAT PEOPLE WHO
STARTED WITH THESE FAKE NEWS
EFFORTS, AN EFFORT TO CONTROL
INFORMATION MORE SO THAN GET RID
OF FAKE NEWS, THEY HAVE NOW
MOVED ON, SOME OF THEM, TOO, YOU
KNOW, WE WILL START TEACHING IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND REQUIRING
THIS AS PART OF THE LAW TO TELL
YOU WHO TO BELIEVE AND IT
USUALLY INVOLVES THEM SAYING, IF
YOU READ IT IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST," YOU CAN
BELIEVE THAT, BUT IF YOU'VE SEEN
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU NEED TO B
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU NEED TO E
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU NEED TO W
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU NEED TO R
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU NEED TO .
IGNORING THE FACT THAT SOME OF
THESE FORMERLY WELL-RESPECTED
NEWS PUBLICATIONS HAVE MADE SOME
OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS ERRORS IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
IT'S NOT THAT SIMPLE.
>> Laura: WE WERE JUST DOING A
SEGMENT ABOUT WHETHER
16-YEAR-OLD SHOULD VOTE.
I THINK DEMOCRATS WANT THEM TO
VOTE BECAUSE THEY ARE FRESH
PAGANS.
THEY ARE IN THE MIDST OF THE
PROPAGANDA MACHINE, ESPECIALLY
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS, PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE RIGHT IN IT.
RIGHT IN THE THICK OF IT.
IT ALL SKEWS DEMOCRATS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT OTHER
FACT-CHECKERS.
THERE IS A NOW A FACT-CHECKER AT
UNIVISION, THE STATISTICS AT
UNIVISION ARE REALLY BAD FOR
REPUBLICANS.
I GUESS 95% OF FACT CHECKS IN
JANUARY OF 2017 TO APRIL OF THIS
YEAR, 95% WENT AGAINST
REPUBLICANS.
0% DEMOCRAT.
2% REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
3% NONPARTISAN.
THAT IS THE MEDIA RESEARCH
CENTER.
UNIVISION, NOT A BIG FAN OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THINK OF THAT IS WHY I TRY TO
SAY THAT WHEN YOU SEE THESE
EFFORTS OF THIRD PARTIES TO CURT
EFFORTS OF THIRD PARTIES TO CURE
YOUR INFORMATION OR TELL YOU
WHAT TO BELIEVE OR TRY TO CURE
TO HIS RIGHT, THAT IS SOMETHING
TO BE SUSPICIOUS OF.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T GET
VALUABLE INFORMATION FROM THEM,
IT'S USUALLY AN EFFORT UNDER A
DIFFERENT NAME BY AN ENTITY THAT
WANTS TO SHAPE THE NARRATIVE AND
SHAPE YOUR OPINION.
>> Laura: AMY KLOBUCHAR,
SENATOR FROM MINNESOTA, WAS ON
TELEVISION THIS WEEK, TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE NEED REGULATIONS ON
FACEBOOK.
I KNOW SOME CONSERVATIVES ARE
VERY FRUSTRATED WITH FACEBOOK.
BUT CODED THAT BACK
CONSERVATIVES?
JUST INDEPENDENT THINKERS?
THE GOVERNMENT TO SAY, WE WILL
REGULATE?
HOW COULD THAT BACKFIRE?
>> ANY TIME A GOVERNMENT OR
THIRD PARTY GETS INTO THE MIX,
PERHAPS ESPECIALLY THE
GOVERNMENT, MAYBE YOU AGREE WITH
HIM TODAY BUT WILL YOU AGREE
WITH THEM TOMORROW?
THAT IS WHY THERE IS A
PHILOSOPHY WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
WAS FOUNDED, TO KEEP HIM OUT OF
CERTAIN THINGS.
WE WANT TO INVITE THEM IN
WHATEVER THEIR GOALS OF THE DAY
MAY BE TO DECIDE WHAT WE SHOULD
SEE AND BELIEVE.
>> Laura: THE TONE OF THE
COVERAGE ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WILL HAVE THIS HISTORIC
MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN.
IF PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD ARRANGED
THIS OR BILL CLINTON, MADELEINE
ALBRIGHT, JOHN KERRY,
HILLARY CLINTON, THIS WOULD
BE -- THIS WOULD BE ALL THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S LIKE IT'S NOT EVEN
HAPPENING.
IT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE.
THE TARIFF, CHINA IS BOWING OUT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE NEVER MOVED ON BEFORE.
THAT WOULD BE COVERED.
IT IS ALMOST LIKE THESE
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUES WHERE
DONALD TRUMP IS REALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE COUNTRY,
THOSE ARE INCONVENIENT FACTS FOR
THIS MEDIA.
GOT TO BE STORMY DANIELS, GOT TO
BE MICHAEL COHEN, GOT TO BE
MUELLER 24/7.
THAT SKEWS THE PUBLIC'S MIND AS
WELL.
>> THERE ARE TWO RELATED FACTORS
I SEE BEHIND THAT.
ONE, THE MEDIA, SOME REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS ARE ALL AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP, FACING
EXTRAORDINARY OPPOSITION.
OTHER THINGS THAT PLAY BUT THEY